La fórmula para el área de un triángulo
es "A" igual a 1/2 de "b" por "h"
donde "A" es igual a área, "b" es igual a longitud
de la base y "h" es igual a longitud de la altura.
Así que "A" es igual a 1/2 de "b" por "h".
Resuelve esta fórmula para la altura.
Déjame dibujar un triángulo por aquí, para
que podamos visualizar estas dimensiones,
aquí tenemos un triángulo, la longitud de
la base "b" es esta distancia de aquí
y la longitud de la altura o simplemente la altura
"h" es ésta de aquí.
Vamos a ponerlo con minúscula que es como
comúnmente se escribe
y nos piden resolver esta fórmula para la altura.
La fórmula es área es igual a 1/2 de base
por altura y nos piden resolver para "h".
Lo que tenemos que hacer es despejar la "h".
"h" se encuentra del lado derecho,
vamos a eliminar lo demás.
Lo que podemos hacer...
podríamos hacer varios pasos a la vez,
pero no, vamos a hacerlo paso a paso.
Eliminemos primero este 1/2, está multiplicando
la "h", la mejor manera de eliminar 1/2 es
multiplicarlo por su recíproco, que en este
caso sería 2 sobre 1 o simplemente 2.
Así es que hagamos eso, multipliquemos por
2, multiplicamos por 2 el lado derecho
y también multiplicamos por 2 el lado izquierdo, recuerda que lo que hagas de un lado,
lo tienes que hacer del otro lado también.
¿Y qué nos queda?
Bueno, hicimos esto de multiplicar por 2 para
que 2 por 1/2 se haga 1, con lo cual del lado
derecho nos queda tan solo "b" por "h" y del
lado izquierdo nos queda 2 por "A", "2A".
Y ya casi acabamos, aquí tenemos "b" que
multiplica a "h" si queremos eliminar esta
"b", vamos a dividir ambos lados de la ecuación
entre "b", dividimos entre "b" el lado derecho
y dividimos entre "b" el lado izquierdo, podemos
considerar la "b" como el coeficiente de la "h",
el cual estamos eliminando dividiendo entre "b".
¿Y que tenemos?
Del lado derecho estas "b" se cancelan y nos
queda tan solo "h" y del lado izquierdo nos
queda "2A" sobre "b".
La ecuación resulta ahora entonces, "h", aquí estoy intercambiando los lados de la ecuación,
"h" que es igual a "2A" entre "b".
Así es que ya hemos resuelto la fórmula
para la altura y ya hemos concluido.
Y esto puede ser útil si alguien te proporciona
una serie de áreas y de bases
y te pide que encuentres las alturas para esos datos,
las alturas de esos triángulos.